Phil told me once, Phil Nash, who organises a bunch of conferences, he told me, I think he said that they get 80% of their submissions in the last 24 hours before closing. So I am definitely one of those people. Leave it to the last minute. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 225 recorded on February 17th, 2025. My name is Connor and today with my cohost Ben, we conclude our conversation with Tristan Brindle. In this episode, we talk about plans for CPP North 2025, plans for flux, the slow death of Twitter and more. Well, I was gonna I mean, I don't know if you were gonna wrap that up, Connor, but I had I was gonna ask Tristan, are you
Phil Nash，一位组织过很多会议的人，曾经告诉我，我想他说过，他们80%的投稿都是在截止日期前的最后24小时内收到的。所以我绝对是那种人，总是拖到最后一刻。欢迎收听ADSP播客第225期，录制于2025年2月17日。我是Connor，今天和我的联合主持人Ben一起，我们结束了与Tristan Brindle的对话。在这一集中，我们讨论了CPP North 2025的计划、Flux的计划、Twitter的缓慢消亡等等。好吧，我本来打算……我是说，我不知道你是否打算结束这个话题，Connor，但我本来想问Tristan，你是否
are you playing? Will we see you in Toronto this year? Oh, yeah, absolutely. Well, all being well, I mean, I'm going to if I get accepted for the CPB North, I'd certainly like to go again. This will be the fourth one, right? This is the fourth, yes. Two of them were at the King Edward Hotel and I believe this one... Last year was at Microsoft. Yeah, I think it's at Microsoft again. July 20th to 23rd.
你打算参加吗？今年我们能在多伦多见到你吗？哦，当然，绝对会。好吧，如果一切顺利的话，我是说，如果我的演讲被CPB North录取了，我当然想再去一次。这将是第四届，对吧？是的，这是第四届。其中两届是在爱德华国王酒店举办的，我相信这一届……去年是在微软举办的。是的，我想今年还是在微软。7月20日到23日。
And Call for Papers is open. Yeah. I know it closes. Today we're recording on February 17th, which is a holiday in Canada. Well, this part of our recording won't maybe come out next week, but part of our recording will. Important dates right at the top. It says call for speakers closes on the 23rd which is six days from now which means by the time you're listening to it the CFP is closed. However, if it gets extended by a month
而且征稿启事已经开放了。是的。我知道它快截止了。我们今天录制的时间是2月17日，这是加拿大的一个假期。好吧，我们录制的这部分内容可能不会在下周播出，但部分内容会。重要的日期就在最上面。上面写着演讲者征集将于23日截止，也就是从现在起六天后，这意味着当你听到这期节目时，CFP已经截止了。不过，如果它延长了一个月的话
sometimes it does get extended. I did see that C++ Now's CFP window got extended. Well, it got extended because of the committee meeting, I think. That was the reason they gave, you know, we're extending it to allow the folks who were at the committee meeting to have time to submit afterwards. Yeah. So, I mean, odds are listeners, if you were thinking of submitting submitting CFP is closed. I'll say now that maybe there was a possibility that Future me according to today, but past me according to when you're hearing this had the energy to insert a CFP closes soon But these days whenever I say if I have the energy I rarely do Or it's not even that I rarely do it's that I don't hear myself reminding me to go and do it So by the time I'm editing in this I've forgotten that I need to add it and then it's a month later
有时确实会延长。我确实看到C++ Now的CFP窗口延长了。嗯，我想是因为委员会会议的原因才延长的。他们给出的理由是，你知道，我们延长它是为了让参加委员会会议的人有时间在之后提交。是的。所以，我的意思是，听众们，如果你当时在考虑提交，CFP已经截止了。我现在要说的是，也许未来的我（相对于今天而言，但相对于你听到这段话时是过去的）有精力插入一句“CFP即将截止”。但这些天，每当我说“如果有精力的话”，我很少真的去做。或者甚至不是我很少做，而是我根本没听到自己在提醒自己去完成它。所以当我编辑这段内容时，我已经忘了需要添加它，然后一个月就过去了。
And I was like oh, yeah, I said I might do that and then I've forgotten. Have you submitted a talk to CPB North? I have not. I am still thinking. I've got a couple different ideas and there's a chance too I might be going to ideas and there's a chance too I might be going to a couple conferences in Australia actually. Oh crikey. And they've got a series of conferences in I believe the three cities are Adelaide, Brisbane and actually I should get this right before although it might not even be on their website right now.
然后我就想，哦，对了，我说过我可能会做那件事，然后我就忘了。你向CPB North提交演讲了吗？我还没有。我还在考虑。我有几个不同的想法，而且实际上我也有可能去参加澳大利亚的几个会议。哦，天哪。我相信他们有一系列会议，三个城市分别是阿德莱德、布里斯班，实际上在说之前我应该确认一下，尽管现在可能还没在他们的网站上。
What are the conferences? The series conferences they're called YOW. Oh, I know them. Which is, yeah, I've seen a ton of their talks. In fact, one of my favorite talks of all time is by an individual, ooh, am I going to forget his name? There's actually two of them and people confuse them all the time. I can just go to my list of every single talk I've ever watched actually.
是什么会议？这一系列会议叫YOW。哦，我知道他们。确实，我看过他们大量的演讲。事实上，我最喜欢的演讲之一是由一个人做的，噢，我会不会忘了他的名字？其实有两个人，人们总是把他们搞混。我其实可以直接查看我观看过的每一个演讲的列表。
And it was, the title of it is Vectors in the title. Yes by Dave Thomas. There's two Dave Thomas's and this is oh Only one of them. There's the Dave Thomas who wrote Ruby on rails. Yeah Am I getting that right? Uh, that might have been. Or is it something else? But this Dave Thomas was heavily involved I think with organizing the GoTo conferences. And Yao was like a sibling or under the same umbrella. And there's a talk that he gave back in 2014 called Living in Big Data with Vector Functional Programming.
标题里有“Vectors”。是的，是Dave Thomas。有两个Dave Thomas，而这个是……只有一个。有一个写了《Ruby on Rails》的Dave Thomas。是的，我没记错吧？呃，可能是吧。或者是什么别的？但这个Dave Thomas深度参与了GoTo会议的组织工作，我想。YOW就像是兄弟会议，或者在同一个旗帜下。他在2014年做过一个演讲，叫《Living in Big Data with Vector Functional Programming》。
And it was one of the talks that I watched back in December of 2019 that was me at the edge of the Alice in Wonderland rabbit hole that is APL and array languages. And it's not online anymore though. It got moved and it actually might be on the Internet Archive. I always forget to check the Internet Archive. Anyways, the point being is they're asking me about topics right now. So I've been trying to think. I will definitely be submitting a talk. But yeah, I mean, I have a bunch of talk topics, but these days, a lot of them are more functional programming, less C++-y. Well, CppNorth is looking for general, has in previous years been looking for general programming talks. Why they actually? As not just C++ specific things, right? I mean, I wrote the first CFP, but I've got to be honest, I actually haven't read it since
那是我在2019年12月观看的演讲之一，当时我正处于APL和数组语言这个“爱丽丝梦游仙境”般兔子洞的边缘。不过它现在不在网上了。它被移动了，实际上可能在互联网档案馆里。我总是忘了去查互联网档案馆。总之，重点是他们现在正在问我关于主题的事。所以我一直在思考。我肯定会提交一个演讲。但是，是的，我有不少演讲主题，但这些天，很多主题更偏向函数式编程，而不是C++。好吧，CppNorth正在寻找通用的，往年也一直在寻找通用的编程演讲。为什么他们实际上？不仅仅是C++特定的东西，对吧？我是说，我写了第一份CFP，但我得诚实地说，我其实从那以后就没读过它了。
I wasn't program chair. So my guess is it has changed. I haven't submitted yet, although I have been, especially in the last few days, I have been, I've been waking up at like 5 a.m. Full of thoughts and having to note them down By the side any any preview thoughts and I will ask Tristan as well because it sounds like you already submitted so me No, I I have not submitted. Yes, and I shouldn't I Shouldn't prejudice the program committee process Phil told me once Phil Nash Nash, who organized a bunch
我不是项目主席。所以我的猜测是它已经变了。我还没提交，虽然我一直在，特别是在过去几天里，我一直在，我早上5点左右醒来，脑子里充满了想法，不得不把它们记下来。在旁边……任何预览想法，我也会问Tristan，因为听起来你已经提交了，所以我……不，我还没有提交。是的，我不应该预判项目委员会的流程。Phil曾经告诉我，Phil Nash，组织了一堆会议的人，他告诉我，我想他说过他们80%的投稿都是在截止日期前的最后24小时内收到的。所以我绝对是那种会拖到最后一刻的人。我通常会在日历上把实际截止日期前的一天标记为“这是截止日期”。所以通常我实际上会提前24小时，但这只是因为我对自己撒谎说截止日期是什么时候，否则我很有可能会错过。但是的，我们可能都处于同样的情况。我本来想绕回来的问题是，你提到了……这可能与我偶然发现的2023年的一个GitHub PR有关，关于Flux未来的设计计划。
of conferences, he told me, I think he said that like they get 80% of their submissions in the last 24 hours before closing. So I am definitely one of those people to leave it to the last minute. I usually put on my calendar one day, one calendar day before the actual deadline that says this is the deadline. And then so usually I'm actually 24 hours in advance but that's only because I lie to myself about when the deadline is otherwise there's a chance I'll end up missing but but yes we might all be in the same spot the question I was gonna circle back to was you you mentioned and it might have to do with this GitHub PR that I came across from 2023, about future design plans for Flux.
PR标题是“扩展内部迭代API”，我不确定这是否是同一件事，但你提到你有潜在的未来设计计划。所以，如果你想和我们以及听众分享那些是什么，如果感兴趣的话，是的，我会很好奇……这开头不错。所以是那个PR，或者我想是一个开放的问题，它演变成了我现在正在思考的东西，因为Flux，对于一个叫Flux的库来说，奇怪的是，它相当稳定。现在它处于一个相当不错的位置。但我确实想做一些改变。其中特别重要的一点是，当我开始时，我真的没有意识到我们正在讨论的这种内部迭代的重要性。因为目前它纯粹是一种优化。
And the PR title is expanding the internal iteration API, which I'm not sure if that's the same thing, but you mentioned that you have potential future design plans. So anyways, if you want to share with us and the listeners what those are, if it's of interest, yeah, I'd be curious to... Way to start. So it is that PR, or I think it's an issue that was open, it kind of morphed into what
如果你很幸运，如果你非常了解这个库，那么你就知道什么时候会触发这个内部迭代代码路径，并且你知道这将会发生。我想要做的是让用户能够确定他们将能够拥有这种良好的内部迭代，使之成为Flux世界的一等公民。所以目前我们有……顺便说一下，真正修复了关于单次遍历序列的设计，
I'm thinking about now because Flux is kind of, strangely for a library called Flux, it's kind of stable. Now it's in kind of a good place. But there are changes I wanna make. And one of the things in particular is when I started, I really didn't realize the importance of this internal iteration that we were talking about. Because right now it's purely an optimization.
因为我一直对Flux中它的工作方式不太满意。所以我过去几个月在笔记本和实验中一直在充实的设计是，拥有一个……无论你怎么称呼它，一个纯粹基于内部迭代的接口或协议。所以我们将有一个序列，你可以对其调用
It's something that if you are lucky, if you know the library very well, then you know when you're going to hit this internal iteration code path and you know that that's going to happen. What I would like to do is to allow users to be sure that they are going to be able to have this nice internal iteration happening, to make that kind of a first class citizen of the Flux world, as it were. So at the moment we have, and while I'm at it, really fixed the design around single pass sequences,
一个函数，我们称之为“iterate”，它执行内部迭代，对吧？所以你将调用这个“iterate”或“iterate while”，或者无论我最终叫它什么。你将传递给它一些谓词，它将遍历序列并为每个函数和每个元素调用你的谓词，直到该谓词返回false，此时迭代停止。现在这实际上比我们目前在C++中拥有的输入迭代器要弱，因为在这个模型中没有指定
because I have never been particularly happy about the way that that works in flux. So the design at the moment that I've kind of been fleshing out in like notebooks and experiments over the past few months is to have a, a whatever you want to call it, an interface, a protocol based purely around internal iteration. So we'll have a sequence is something on which you can call
如果你尝试在谓词返回false后重新开始迭代会发生什么。在这个模型中，如果你尝试重新开始迭代会发生什么是不确定的，因为如果你想一想，如果你在像vector这样的东西上做这件事，最自然的做法是从头开始重新迭代。而如果你使用像流（stream）这样的东西，比如C++输入流，那么从你离开的地方继续下去是很自然的。对。对。所以对于这种新的基本序列API，基于内部迭代的基础，它
a function, let's call it iterate, that performs internal iteration, right? So you will call this iterate or iterate while, or whatever I end up calling it. And you will pass it some predicates and it will iterate through the sequence and call your predicate for each function and for each element until that predicate returns false at which point iteration stops. Now this is actually kind of weaker than the input iterators that we have in C++ at the moment, because it's unspecified in this model
将是不确定的。所以你真的只需要编写那些在某处停止然后就完成的算法，这很好。我们可以做到。但这意味着你使用此协议编写的算法比你今天使用C++中的输入迭代器或Flux中现有的单次遍历模型所能编写的算法稍微有限一些。所以这算是规模的一端。然后我想做的另一件事是保留当前的游标模型，但仅用于多次遍历序列。
what happens if you try to restart iteration after, you know, if your predicate returns false, we stop iterating. And then it's unspecified in this model what happens if you try to restart iteration, because if you think about it, if you're doing this over something like a vector, the natural thing to do would be to restart iteration from the beginning again. Whereas if you're using something like a stream, like a C++ input stream, then it's natural to just pick up from where you left off. Right. Right. And so for this new kind of basic sequence API, the base around internal iteration, it's
所以我们目前的模型是，增量和解引用（即访问）的操作是分开的操作。这与C++迭代器相同。这对于多次遍历序列非常非常有效。也就是说，我们可以反复获取同一个元素，
going to be unspecified what happens. So really you need to only write algorithms that just stop somewhere and then they are complete, which is fine. We can do that. But it means that the algorithms that you write using this protocol are slightly more limited than what you can write today with input iterators in C++ or with the single pass model as it currently exists in Flux. So that's kind of one end of the scale. And then the other thing that I want to do is to have the current cursor model keep that that but only for multi-pass sequences.
获取同一个元素。前向迭代器。因为它们有，是的，它们有位置的概念，对吧，这基本上是多次遍历序列。它们有一些位置的概念。我们可以拥有我们所说的游标，对应于一个位置，并且能够复制游标来保存位置是很自然的，并且能够复制游标
So the current model that we have is that the operations of increment and dereference that is access, these are separate operations. This is the same as with C++ iterators. And that works really, really well for multi-pass sequences. That is where we can repeatedly get the same element,
来保存位置并回到它那里是很自然的。所以这个API对于多次遍历序列非常有效。然而，它对于纯单次遍历序列的效果并不那么好。所以我计划，一方面，我们有内部迭代方案来完成我们目前在Flux中用单次遍历几乎能做到的事情。而在另一端引入，
get the same element out. Forward iterators. Because these have, yeah, these have a notion of position, right, that's kind of fundamentally multi-pass sequences. They have some idea of position. We can have the cursor as we call it, corresponds to a position and it is natural to be able to copy a cursor to like save a position and it is natural to be able to copy a cursor
看看我目前的东西，因为我想叫它“collection”。这个协议将被命名为“collection”，用于基于游标的多次遍历。这在功能中间留下了一个小缺口，即那些需要你能够重新开始迭代，但不是多次遍历的东西。对吧？你明白我的意思吗？我想是的。是的，也许我没有解释……嗯，所以有一个问题，嗯，比如，是否需要在中间存在第三种协议，用于那些不是多次遍历，但我们知道重新开始时会发生什么的情况。对吧。而且，不幸的是，我认为我们确实需要一些东西来填补这个空白。所以这是一个有趣的设计问题，如何很好地做到这一点，以及如何逐步实现这一点，以便用户确切地知道在每个点会发生什么。他们不会对此感到惊讶。
to like save a position and to come back to it. And so this API works really well for multi-pass sequences. However, it doesn't work so well for pure single-pass sequences. So I'm planning to kind of, on the one hand, we have the internal iteration scheme to do almost what we can currently do with single pass influx. And at the other end to introduce,
但是的，这是那种在纯音频中很难描述的事情之一，如果我在做演示，我可以向你展示幻灯片，解释起来会容易得多，但无论如何，Flux世界正在发生令人兴奋的事情，也许……也许我应该做一个关于它的演讲，谁知道呢。听起来是个绝妙的主意。听起来是个绝妙的主意。我的意思是，这很有趣，有人，你怎么称呼它，在Mastodon上发推文（缺乏更好的词），回应了Arraycast上发生的一场讨论，关于发现许多这些数组语言实现使用了……它们在每种语言中叫法不同，但类似于存储关于数组属性的元数据或属性的数组。
and look at my current thing, because I want to call it collection. The protocol is going to be called collection for like multi-pass based on cursors. And that leaves us with just a little gap in the middle in functionality, which is things that require you to be able to restart iteration, but are not multi-pass. Right? Do you follow where I'm coming from? I think so. Yeah, maybe I'm not expe... Um, and so there's a question of, um, like, does there need to be a kind of a third kind
所以例如，如果你对一个数组进行排序，你可以根据操作的内容将其分派到非常非常高效的算法中。所以你知道，最大值，显然，为什么要在排序后求最大值？但那是一个O1操作。有趣的是，有一堆操作你知道最终会得到排序信息。所以一个最大值扫描，你最终会得到排序信息。所以这是一组你附加到数组上的元数据，
of protocol in the middle for things that are not multi-pass, but where we know what happens when we restart. Right. And, unfortunately, I think that we actually do need something to fill this gap. So it's kind of an interesting design thing of how to do this nicely and how to implement this kind of progressively so that users know exactly what's going to happen at each point in there. They're not surprised about it.
使你能够基本上分派到单个算法中具有不同复杂度的不同算法。有人在Mastodon上评论说，这与C++中迭代器发生的情况并无不同。你可能根据你拥有的迭代器有几种不同的算法实现。Rotate，很有名。那正是我们可能在几十集前与Sean Parent进行的对话。我相信D语言做了类似的事情。
But yeah, it's one of these things that's quite hard to describe when it's audio only and if I was doing a presentation I could show you the slides and it would make it much easier to explain but anyway exciting things happening in the flux world and maybe maybe I should do a talk about it who knows it sounds like a fantastic idea Sounds like a fantastic idea. I mean it's interesting this, someone, what do you call it, tweet for lack of a better word on Mastodon, tweeted in response to a discussion that happened on Arraycast about the discovery that a bunch of these array language implementations use the, they're called different things in each language, but like arrays that store like metadata or attributes about the properties of the array.
他们有一种排序范围类型。所以如果你做……如果你调用find，它不是做线性搜索，而是做二分搜索，我相信，我不记得确切的细节了。但这里肯定有相似之处。我只是觉得这非常……就像你说的，这是我现在发现自己经常思考的事情，就我从数组语言的角度思考它而言，但它适用于很多不同的空间，无论是C++中的概念形式，还是迭代器类型，或者是你持有的某种元数据形式，有时即使你要做……这就是BQM的创建者Marshall所说的……元数据，你持有的有时即使你要
So for instance, if you sort an array, you can then dispatch the next operation, depending on what it is to a very, very efficient. So you know, a maximum, obviously, why would you be doing a maximum after a sort? But that's an O1 operation. And what's interesting is that there are a bunch of operations where you know you end up with sorted info. So a max scan, you end up with sorted info. So it's this set of metadata that you attach to your arrays
如果你要进行排序，你知道最明智的做法是先进行检查，线性检查，它是否已经排序了，如果是的话，你就完成了。但在做那个检查时，你实际上可以计算出一些元数据，你知道，比如，如果你在检查它是否已排序，你正在设置那个标志，但还有其他几个……取决于你正在跟踪的元数据集合，你实际上可以……你可以得到范围，你知道，在检查它是否已排序时，即使它没有排序，你仍然可以得到最小值和最大值。是的。所以你可以很好地开始计算枢轴，例如。
that enable you to dispatch to basically like different algorithms within a single algorithm that have different complexities. And someone on Macedon commented that this was not dissimilar to what happens in C++ with iterators. You potentially have several different algorithm implementations depending on the iterator that you have. Rotate, famously. That was the conversation that we had with Sean Parent just maybe tens of episodes ago now. I believe D does something like this.
是的，是的。总之，这非常有趣，基本上这就是你在这里谈论的，Tristan，提出这种你称之为集合和序列以及多次遍历的层次结构。这基本上分派到具有不同性能特征的不同实现。我以为这是我脑子里的一个想法，然后我发现了这些数组语言。然后Mastodon上的那个人指出了这一点，我就想，也许这实际上只是到处都在发生的常见事情，只是没有一个统称。
They have a sorted range type. And so then if you do like, if you call find on this, instead of doing a linear search, it does a binary search, I believe, I can't remember the exact details. But there's definitely like a similarity here. And I just find it incredibly, like you said, it's something that I find myself thinking about a lot now in terms of I think about it from the array language angle, but it's applicable in a ton of different spaces where like whether it's in the form of concepts in C++ or iterator types or it's in this form of some kind of metadata that you're holding onto that sometimes even if you're going to do like that was what Marshall, the creator of BQM was of metadata that you're holding on to that sometimes even if you're
嗯，我认为这个想法是，你能给编译器提供的信息越多越好，对吧？而且你受限于你工作的级别。所以C++中的一切都是基于迭代器的，范围也是基于迭代器的。所以那里的限制是，没有一种很好的方式来描述集合的属性。有些情况下范围会发生这种情况，我想。但就像你说的，如果你不在……或者除了在迭代器或游标级别，如果你在集合级别工作，那么你可以在运行某些算法后表达集合的属性。这给了编译器更多的优化空间。是的，我们实际上在范围中看到了这一点，因为传统上范围只是一个迭代器对，而实际的容器类型本身有时拥有更多它无法仅通过其迭代器传达的信息。所以我总是想到标准列表（std::list），它知道它有多少个元素，但它的迭代器不是随机访问的。你不能仅通过迭代器接口询问。
if you're gonna do like that was what uh marshall the creator of bqm was saying you know if you're gonna do a sort you know the smartest thing to do is to do a a check up front a linear check is this already sorted um and if so like you're done but in doing that check you can actually compute some of this metadata you know like right if you're checking if it's sorted you're setting that flag but there's a couple other depending on the set of metadata that you're tracking, you can actually do like get that you can get the range, you know, in checking if it's sorted even if it's not sorted, you can still get the minimum and the maximum value. Yeah. So you can get a good start on computing a pivot, for example.
你不能对其进行距离计算和操作。完全正确。完全正确。是的。我有一段时间没意识到这一点。在……之间存在差异。或者也许这是另一个问题。但比如std::ranges::distance与std::distance根据序列有不同的运行时。现在我认为如果你在大小范围上调用std::ranges::distance，它会调用std::ranges::size，这保证是常数时间。而我认为std::distance只是
Yeah, yeah. Anyway, so it's just it's very interesting that basically that's what you're talking about here, Tristan, is coming up with this kind of hierarchy of what you would call collections and sequences and multi-pass. And this basically dispatches to different implementations which have different performance characteristics. And I thought that this was a thing that I had in my head, and then I discovered these array languages. And then the individual on Mast on Macedon pointed out and I was like, maybe this is just actually like a common thing that happens all over the place, but there's just no collective term for.
总是计算增量次数直到到达末尾。Distance使用的是原始迭代器模型。所以如果你有双向或前向迭代器，它必须是O(n)。是的，我想我当时……我是在一个演讲中发现或被告知的，当时我有一张使用std::distance的幻灯片，然后有人举手说，我是说，我知道这是幻灯片内容，但你可能好奇知道……我就说我非常好奇，谢谢，这值得放入下一个版本中，因为那是一个……但有些人更喜欢调用
Well, I think the idea is like the more information you can give the compiler, the better, right? And you are limited by which level you're working at. So everything in C++ is based around iterators, and ranges are also based on iterators. So the limitation there is there isn't a really good way to describe a property of a collection. There are some things where there are some cases that happens with ranges, I guess. But like you were saying, like if you work not
std::distance或std::ranges::distance，因为这会给你一个有符号值，而std::size或std::ranges::size给你一个无符号值，人们更喜欢使用有符号值。所以有些人选择无论如何都使用distance函数。但是，所以我们添加了std::ranges::ssize，我想，正是出于那个原因。我们都爱C++。
at the... or as well as at the iterator or the cursor level, if you work at the collection level, then you can express properties of the collections after having run certain algorithms. And that gives the compiler more grist to optimize. Yes and we actually see this in ranges actually because traditionally a range was just an iterator pair whereas the actual container type itself sometimes has more information that it cannot convey just via its iterators. So the example I always think of is standard list, which knows how many elements it has, but its iterators are not random access. You can't ask just by the iterator interface.
好吧，我们已经超过一小时了，有什么最后的想法、评论，你知道，要与听众分享的热门观点吗？预测，我是说Bryce和我上次做了一些预测，如果你有2025年的……我是说，在这一点上，这些预测是在一年半之后做出的，要到三月左右才会出来。但抛出一个篮球看看它是否落入篮筐总是很有趣的。我是说，就过去几周世界似乎发生的一切而言，我不认为我想对今年剩下的时间做任何预测。是的，谁知道呢，谁知道会发生什么。是的，我不会做任何预测，我有更多的希望而不是预测。
You can't distance it and order an operation on. Exactly. Exactly. Yes. I didn't realize that for a while. There was a difference between. Or maybe this is a different issue. But like stood ranges distance versus stood distance has different runtime depending on the sequence. Now I think standard ranges distance if you call it on a sized range, it will call standard ranges size, which is guaranteed to be a constant time. Whereas I think standard distance just
有道理。好吧。那么直到下次……我是说，Cpp North在七月。我是说，我应该……我们应该问Tristan，宣传一下你的所有东西，还有对于今年可能想在会议上打招呼的听众，你有计划吗？还有你还在做培训之类的吗？我是说，宣传一下你的所有东西。我不知道为什么我还在……是的，所以我希望……我还没有确认任何会议。我不幸错过了CCU，这是英国接下来要举办的会议，但我希望……我很乐意再次去多伦多的Cpp North。希望我能去C++ on Sea，这是英国举办的另一个会议。也许CppCon晚些时候……
always counts the number of increments until it gets to the end. Distance is using the original iterator model. So if you have a bidi or a forward iterator, it has to be order n. Yeah, I think I was, I discovered that or was told that in a slide, in a talk where I had a slide using std distance and then someone raised their hand and was like, I mean, I know it's slideware, but you might be curious to know and I was like I am very curious to know that thank you that is something worth putting in the next version of this because that's a yeah but then some people prefer to call
今年，谁知道呢。所以是的，如果你在英国，来参加C++ London，伦敦聚会。我总是去参加那些。我现在是联合组织者之一，算是吧。所以是的，还有什么我应该宣传的？我一直在谈论Flux，所以那会让人厌烦。我技术上还在Twitter上，账号是Tristan Brindle，虽然我不怎么用它。Blue Sky，我的账号是@tristanbrindle.com。如果你感兴趣的话，LinkedIn可能是最好的，因为那真的很无聊。但是的，那就是我。顺便说一句，谢谢你再次邀请我。我不知道为什么你一直邀请我，因为……因为对话很有趣。我怀疑是的，你是算法的候选名单……你知道，如果有一组
standard distance or send of ranges distance anyway because that gives you a signed value whereas standards size standard range size gives you an unsigned value and people prefer working with signed values. So some people choose to use did the distance function anyway. But there, so we added standard ranges S size, I think, for precisely that reason. We all love C++. Oh yeah.
集合，我不知道数字是五还是十，如果我正在收集……你知道，热衷于谈论算法的人的圆桌会议，你在那个名单上，所以不，这总是……这总是一种荣幸。我总是玩得很开心。我喜欢那些……嗯，我喜欢那一集中你对Bryce说“这是测验”的那五分钟。我面前有一份算法列表。你能说出多少个？哦，是的，是的，是的。事实是，我听那些剧集时，我就想，他们肯定会提到这个。他们肯定会提到这个。他们不可能不提到这个。然后，正如你所知，之后我就想，哦，他们没提到那个。我需要和Garret谈谈。在220多集里，有两位数的次数，你知道，下一次跟进时，就像我们必须亲自向Sean Parent道歉，因为没有读过EOP的第三章，不知道插入的东西。
All right, well we're past the hour mark are there any final final thoughts comments, you know Hot takes to be shared with the listener Predictions, I mean we Bryce and I did some predictions last time if you got some 20 25 I mean at this point these predictions are happening a month and a half into the year and won't be coming out until like March But it's always still fun to you know throw up a basketball see if it lands in the hoop. I mean just with everything that seems to have happened in the world in the last couple of weeks I don't think I want to make any predictions for the rest of this year. Yeah who knows who knows what's going to. Yeah I'm not gonna make any predictions I have I have more hopes than predictions
是的，我是说，这就是这个播客的美妙之处，对于我们无知的时刻，希望下一次，我们从无知中吸取了教训，现在知道了这件事。而且，我是说，关于Twitter的话题，我本来想提一下，我认为它实际上正在缓慢消亡，因为我非常确定我发推文说那个后端排名，Flux排名第一。
Fair enough. Alrighty. Well until until next time I mean Cpp north is in July. I mean I should we should ask Tristan plug all your stuff and also For the listener that may want to say hi if you're at a conference this year Do you have plans to and also are you still doing training and stuff? I mean plug up plug all your stuff I don't know why I'm still yeah, so I'm hope I don't have any confirmed conferences yet. I unfortunately I missed out on a CCU Which is the next one that's happening in the UK, but I hope I would love I would love to again go to Toronto Cpp North. Hopefully I'll be able to go to C++ on C which is the other one that happens in the UK. Maybe CppCon later this
当我查看我个人资料上的媒体时，一半只是黑方块或者你无法点击的东西。所以我认为媒体是……每个人都说他们不……你知道，这几乎是一样的。这是我注意到的第一个巨大差异，那就是我的……我认为Twitter对我来说最大的价值是，它实际上是我可以去截图并有时包含在演讲中的东西，当我发现
year, who knows. So yes, if you are in the UK, come along to C++ London, the London Meetup. I always go to those. I'm one of the co-organizers now, sort of. So yes, what else was there I was supposed to plug? I've been talking all about Flux, so that will bore people. I'm technically on Twitter still at Tristan Brindle, although I don't use it very much. Blue Sky, my handle is at tristanbrindle.com. Train stuff if you're interested, kind of LinkedIn is probably best for that because that's really boring. But yes, that's me. Thank you for having me on again, by the way. I don't know why you keep inviting me because... Because the conversation is interesting. I suspect yeah You're on the short list of algorithm. You know if there's a like a set of
某些东西时，我会发推文，只是为了将来截图的目的，但现在……媒体的历史似乎正在消失。所以，因为我非常确定我发了那条推文。总之，我们会确保链接到Twitter和Blue Sky。或者你要补充说Ben，你……或者你说你已经离开Twitter了？是的，我删除了我所有的推文。我只是……我没有看它，嗯，我在2020年停止发推文，我只是取消了关注。我经历了一个逐渐取消关注的过程，然后，你知道，六……
collection, I don't know if the numbers five or ten or whatever if I'm collecting you know the roundtable of People excited to talk about algorithms you you're on that list so No, it's always it's always a pleasure. I always have a good time. I enjoy the episodes where, well, I enjoy the five minutes of the episode where you say to Bryce, here's the quiz. I've got a list of the algorithms in front of me. How many can you name? Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. The truth is, I listen to those episodes and I'm like, most of the episodes I listen to,
你发现自己关注数为零。不，我仍然……你知道，我仍然有一些粉丝，我甚至不知道有多少，但我随着时间的推移削减了我关注的人。每隔几个月我就会醒来，我就想，哦，让我们再次削减我的关注列表，再去掉50个。然后大约三个月前，我删除了所有东西。我想我个人认识的几乎所有我曾经关注的人都不再在Twitter或X上发推文了。有一堆组织还没有转移到Blue Sky或其他
I'm like, surely they're going to mention this in a minute. Surely they're going to mention this in a minute. They can't not mention this. And then, as you know, and then afterwards I'm like, oh, they didn't mention that. I need to talk to Garret. There's a double digit number of times at this point through 220 plus episodes where, you know, the next follow up, it's like we've got to apologize personally to Sean Parent for not having read the third chapter of EOP and not knowing about insert thing.
平台上，我关注的新闻和体育内容，但这就是我现在从Twitter上得到的一切。实际的个人内容。是的。Twitter对我来说现在处于遗产领域。我仍然在那里拥有账户的唯一原因是与一两个人进行私信。Facebook也是一样。我刚才正要说
And yes, I mean, that's the part of the beauty of this podcast, is for the times that we are ignorant, hopefully the next time, we've learned from our ignorance and now know the thing. And I mean, on the topic of Twitter, I meant to mention that I think it is actually slowly dying because the reason I'm pretty sure I tweeted that ranking of backends where Flux was number one.
同样的话，关于Facebook。我实际上再也不去Facebook.com了，或者像千载难逢一样。他们有messenger.com网站，你可以直接去那里。因为我聊天的大多数人都在WhatsApp上，但仍有几个人主要使用Messenger。所以，我是说，归根结底是同一家公司。
And when I went to the media on my profile, half of it is just black squares or like things you can't click on. So I think the media is like, everyone has said that they don't, you know, it's pretty much the same. This is the first mega difference I've noticed is that my and that is I think the best value for me in Twitter is it's actually like a source of things that I can go and screenshot and include in talk sometimes when I know I've
但是的，Twitter还没到那一步。但当我看到我过去的推文消失时，我就想，这是……而且，搜索功能曾经非常棒。它仍然很棒，但你必须去高级搜索并输入人们的账号，从……然后是关键词。你曾经只需要去@人的用户名
discovered something I'll go and tweet it just for the sole purpose of screenshotting it in the future but now now the history of media seems to be disappearing. So, because I'm pretty sure I tweeted that. And anyway, so we will make sure to link to both the Twitter and Blue Sky. Or you're going to add Ben that you, or you said you're off of Twitter though. Yeah, I deleted all of my tweets. I just, I haven't looked at it in, well, I stopped tweeting in 2020 and I just unfollowed. I went through a gradual process of unfollowing more and more and then, you know, six.
然后是你想要的关键词。所以总之，你知道，它确实看起来像Twitter正在消亡，是的，Mastodon和Blue Sky。虽然Blue Sky还有一些工作要做。为什么他们有单独的视频和图片按钮？嗯，这之间的设计选择是什么？因为我总是点击图片那个，然后我就想，我知道我的视频……哦，对了。我点击了图片那个，然后我得回去。它是开源的，Connor，你可以提交一个PR，是的，你可以修复它，你不必
You found yourself at zero follows. No, I still, you know, I still had some followers and I don't even know how many, but I trimmed back the people I was following over time. Every few months I would wake up and I would be like, oh, let's just trim my follower list again, take out another 50. And then three months ago or so, I just removed everything. I think almost everybody I know personally that I used to follow is no longer tweeting on Twitter or X. There are a bunch of organizations that haven't moved over to Blue Sky or other
抱怨。整个社交媒体，我越来越觉得不值得我花时间，就像我曾经从社交媒体获得的所有价值，现在我从认识像你们这样的人，从参加聚会中获得。诸如此类。参加你当地的聚会。是的。好吧，我没有当地的聚会。我有一个当地的会议。
platforms yet, news and sport things that I follow, but that's all I get from Twitter now. The actual personal stuff. Yeah. Twitter's in the realm of a legacy for me now. The only reason I still have an account there is for DMs with one or two people. It's the same way with Facebook. I was literally just going to say
不是你。听众通常应该参加当地的聚会，伦敦或丹佛，或编程语言虚拟聚会。Tristan，如果你想来丹佛聚会演讲，你会非常受欢迎。我们总是……哦，你，Carla。Ben说的，去参加你当地的聚会，无论在哪里。
the same thing with Facebook. I actually never go to Facebook.com anymore, or like in a blue moon. They have the messenger.com site where you just directly go for it. Because most folks I chat to on WhatsApp, but there's still a couple that primarily use Messenger. And so, I mean, same company at the end of the day.
这些天似乎有不少，至少从疫情时期它们都是虚拟的时候开始。丹佛聚会是混合的。我们倾向于只做现场演讲，但我们有很多在线参加的人。换句话说，演讲者是实体的。很高兴知道。我们将链接到丹佛的那个，我们将链接到C++ London的那个，我们将链接到……如果你有其他聚会，我想我几次前链接到了布达佩斯的那个。但你想说什么，Tristan？哦，只是关于链接到东西的话题，因为我应该提到这一点，
But yeah, Twitter's not there for me yet. But when I saw that my past tweets were gone, I was like, this is, and also too, the search engine, the search functionality used to be amazing. It still is, but you have to go to advanced search and plug in people's handles for from, and then the keywords. You used to just be able to go at person's username
哦，大约三集前，现在可能了。有一个叫Bob Nystrom的人写了几篇很棒的博文，你可能认识。游戏编程模式，Dart语言。Crafting Interpreters。此外，他就是那个提出“函数着色”这个术语的人，我相信。那是他的。但总之，他有几篇2013年的博文，叫《Iteration Inside and Out》。
and then the keywords that you wanted. So anyways, you know it does it does actually seem to me like Twitter's dying and Yeah, I mastered on in blue sky. Although I'm blue sky It's got some work to do. Why do they have a separate button for videos and images? Well, what's the design choice between that because I always click on the images one and I was like, I know my video Oh, right. I clicked on the picture one then I got to go back It's open source Connor you can submit a PR yeah you can fix it you don't have to
所以我肯定我们会把链接放在节目说明中。但我认为我没有很好地解释内部迭代。但他在这篇博客中，在这些文章中解释了。所以是的，如果你感兴趣，强烈推荐去看看那些。太棒了，是的。我会在这集和我们谈论Flux和内部迭代的剧集中链接它，以及Flux的链接。我是说，如果你是长期听众，这不是你第一次听说它了。
complain social media as a whole is I'm feeling increasingly not worth my time like like all the value I used to get from social media now I get from knowing the people like yourselves from going to meetups. Things like that. Attend your local meetup. Yeah. Well, I don't have a local meetup. I got a local conference.
但它正在成为，我想……C++ on Sea的演讲是那个吗？所以我可以提供。有几个人可能在听，心想，哦，我可以去看那个演讲吗？所以我……演讲和其中一些演讲被录制了。我从组织会议的人那里得到可靠消息，他们认为他们说可能需要几周，两到三周。
Not you. Listeners in general should attend the local meetups, London or Denver, or programming languages virtual. Tristan, if you wanna come talk at the Denver meetup, you'd be very welcome. We're always, oh, you, Carla. What Ben said, go attend your local meetup, wherever that is.
然而，除非它是一个隐身、不可发现的YouTube频道，或者也许它发布在其他地方。我从来没能找到这些在线内容。录制确实发生了。房间里有摄像机，镜头也在拍摄，所以我的猜测是这只是优先级问题，他们可能正忙于准备下一次会议，这在他们的待办事项列表中优先级较低。所以是的，目前它不可用。幻灯片在那里，如果你下载PDF，确实有那个排名表。
There seems to be quite a bit of them these days, at least from pandemic days when they were all virtual. The Denver meetup is hybrid. We tend to only do in-person talks, but we have plenty of people who attend online. In other words, the speaker is physical. Good to know. We will link to the Denver one, we will link to the C++ London one, we will link to... If you've got other meetups, I think I linked to the Budapest one a couple times ago. But what were you gonna say Tristan? Oh, just on the subject of linking to things, because I should have mentioned this,
但当它上线时，因为我确实每两三周检查一次，但老实说，通常发生的情况是，当有人发布它时，我会被添加到某些社交媒体上，然后我就会想，啊，在这里，我终于等到了这个。所以这是一个长答案，短答案是，不，它还没上线，但应该会在晚些时候上线。好吧，这太棒了。直到下次。我是说，希望，是的，我们会见到彼此，要么在多伦多，要么在不同的会议上，是的，这太棒了。希望大家喜欢，带走了一些电影推荐和一个库推荐。再次感谢邀请我。绝对的。谢谢。直到下次。一定要在你的播客应用中或在ADSPthepodcast.com上查看这些节目说明，获取任何内容的链接。绝对的，Tristan。谢谢，Tristan。直到下次。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
oh, about three episodes ago, possibly now. There's a great couple of blog posts by a guy called Bob Nystrom, who you might know. Game programming patterns, Dart language. Crafting interpreters. Also, he's the person who came up with the term function colouring, I believe. That was his. But anyway, he has a couple of blog posts from 2013 called Iteration Inside and Out.
哦，大概是三集之前，可能现在也是。有一个叫Bob Nystrom的人写了几篇很棒的博客文章，你可能认识他。他写过《游戏编程模式》、《Dart语言》和《Crafting Interpreters》。我相信“函数着色”这个术语也是他提出来的。总之，他在2013年写了几篇名为《Iteration Inside and Out》的博客文章。
So I'm sure we'll put the link in the show notes. But I didn't do a great job of explaining internal iteration, I don't think. But he does in this blog, in these posts. So yeah, highly recommended if you're interested to go and check those out. Awesome, yeah. I will link that in this episode and in the episodes where we talked about flux and internal iteration, as well as a link to flux. I mean, if you're a long time listener, this isn't the first time you've heard about it.
所以我肯定会把链接放在节目说明里。我觉得我之前没能很好地解释内部迭代，但他在这些博客文章里解释得很清楚。所以，如果你感兴趣，强烈推荐去看看。太棒了，是的。我会把链接放在这一集以及我们讨论Flux和内部迭代的那些集里，同时也会提供Flux的链接。我的意思是，如果你是老听众，这已经不是你第一次听说它了。
But it is becoming, I think... the C++ under the C talk is that so I had available. There is a couple of people probably listening being like, oh, can I go watch that talk? So I the talks and I'm one of the talks were recorded. And I had it on good authority from the people running the conference that they thought they said that probably a couple of weeks, two to three weeks. the people running the conference that they thought they said that probably a couple weeks two to three weeks However, unless if it's like a incognito
但我认为它正在变得……关于“C++下的C”那个演讲，我当时在场。可能有一些听众会想，我能去看看那个演讲吗？演讲确实被录制了。我有可靠消息来源，会议组织者当时说可能需要几周，两到三周的时间。然而，除非它是在一个隐秘的、无法发现的YouTube频道上，或者发布在其他地方。
indiscoverable YouTube channel or maybe it's posted somewhere else. I have never been able to find These online yet. The recordings did happen. There were cameras in the room and footage being filmed so my guess is it's just priorities they're probably in the midst of preparing for the next conference and this is a lower priority on their list of things to do. So yeah, currently it's not available. The slide deck is there, which does have that little table of rankings of stuff if you download the PDF.
我至今还没能在网上找到它们。录制确实进行了，房间里有摄像机在拍摄，所以我猜这只是优先级的问题，他们可能正忙于筹备下一届会议，这在他们的待办事项中优先级较低。所以，目前它还不可用。幻灯片是有的，如果你下载PDF，里面确实有那个关于各种东西排名的表格。
But when it does come online, because I do check I'd say once every two or three weeks, but honestly usually what happens is I'll get added on some social media when someone posts it and then I'll be like, ah, here it is, I was finally waiting for this. So that's a long answer to the short answer being, no, it's not online yet, but should be later. All right, this has been a blast. Until next time. I mean, hopefully, yeah we'll see each other all either in Toronto or maybe a different conference and Yeah, this has been this has been a blast. Hopefully folks enjoyed came away with a couple movie recommendations and a one library recommendation Thanks again for having me. Absolutely. Thanks. Until next time Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast com for links to anything Absolutely, Tristan. Thanks, Tristan. Until next time. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但当它上线时——因为我确实每两三周会检查一次，但通常情况是，当有人发布它时，我会在社交媒体上被艾特，然后我会想，啊，终于等到了。所以，对于那个简短问题的长回答是：不，它还没上线，但以后应该会有的。好了，这次聊得很开心。下次见。希望我们能在多伦多或其他会议上见面。这次真的非常愉快。希望大家听得开心，并带走了一些电影推荐和一个库的推荐。再次感谢邀请我。绝对的，谢谢。下次见。请务必在你的播客应用或ADSPthepodcast.com查看节目说明，获取相关链接。绝对的，Tristan。谢谢，Tristan。下次见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。